If the enigmatic Zava struck a chord
of recognition in the third season of
"Ted Lasso," it wasn't just his magnetic presence.
The actor who plays him has built up
quite a resume over the past decade.
No "Ted Lasso" character has been quite as
inscrutable as Zava. Modeled after other
legendary single-named footballers of similar
brilliance and ego, the star player dazzled
on the field and brought Richmond close to
the top of the table in the Premier League,
only to bail midseason after
the squad started to struggle.
Before his shocking departure, he puzzled
his teammates with a combination of prima
donna behavior and enigmatic locker room quips,
ruffled the feathers of teammate Jamie Tartt,
prompted Thierry Zoreaux to
change his name to Van Damme,
and informed Sam Obisanya that Nigerian
cooking will change considerably.
"West African cuisine doesn't
typically feature a lot of avocados."
"Not yet."
Zava plays a crucial thematic role in Season
3 of "Ted Lasso." Maximillian Osinski,
who plays the mononymous footballer, told Vulture,
"I think he was brought on as this foil,
to show the team that they can't lean on
one individual. They have to work together."
His decision to suddenly retire from
football, and without even informing Ted,
has thrown a wrench into Richmond's
already malfunctioning gears. Most likely,
the sudden retirement is not the last we've
heard from Zava, especially considering how
heavily he was schmoozing with Rupert Mannion,
owner of Richmond's sworn enemy, West Ham United.
So where may you have seen Osinski before? Well,
how about the MCU? S.H.I.E.L.D. agent James Davis,
played by Osinski, first shows up in the ninth
episode of "Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D." He isn't seen
again until the fourth season, when he becomes
a recurring character. He had left S.H.I.E.L.D.
in the interim, but rejoins under Agent Phil
Coulson's leadership, proving himself to be a
loyal agent. He's killed in the final season after
being possessed by the malevolent entity Izel.
"I did warn you. Could be worse."
In the midst of his run as a secret agent,
Osinski took to the waves on TNT's "The Last
Ship." Set in a world in which a virus had wiped
out 80 percent of the global population, the show
zoomed in on a crew of just 218 aboard a single
U.S. Navy ship at sea, the U.S.S. Nathan James,
saddled with the job of finding a
cure. Even among that small crew,
Osinski's lookout Derek Evans wasn't
seen more than a handful of times in just
three episodes. He's not a prominently
featured face, but a face nonetheless.
Notably, Osinksi got to work with his now-wife,
Australian-Nepalese actor Dichen Lachman, on both
"The Last Ship" and "Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D."
Osinski is also part of the quickly expanding
universe of AMC's "The Walking Dead." He appeared
in the second and final season of "The Walking
Dead: World Beyond" as Dennis Graham, husband
of fan-favorite Jennifer "Huck" Mallick. "World
Beyond" mostly looks at the post-zombie apocalypse
through the eyes of the teenage characters
nicknamed the Endlings. Like most adults on
the show, Dennis is haunted by his past, grasping
for redemption. Osinski told Pop Culturalist,
"I asked myself, 'Why didn't he fall to
the side and become a shell of himself?'
With a character like Dennis, it's
about trying to figure out what a
person does or how they function while
dealing with issues of their past."
Dennis is a decent man who made a grave and
deadly mistake during his time with the Civic
Republic Military. Silas calls him one of the
few good people who have been part of the C.R.M.,
and Dennis and Huck are increasingly disturbed
by the Civic Republic's violence against innocent
people. The two even join the Endlings to stop
the C.R.M.'s planned gas attack on Portland. After
Huck dies in the explosion that destroys the gas,
a mortally wounded Dennis convinces Silas to shoot
him so that the latter can come off as a hero to
the Civic Republic and continue to undermine it.